alright final part of our year in review
I want to talk to these guys about
whether this was a good year or a bad
year for the US for the world for the
young turks for us personally america
had us very up and down year i think
between the NSA and drones and
everything with obamacare and all that
stuff did is this a net gain or a net
loss for America's is a good year for
America arm now i sound like a cable
news person that we would make fun of
with these stupid now I'm bullying the
heart of it I'm gonna say that there's a
lot of disparaging things or dis
dispiriting I don't know that severity
or discourage discouraging things that
happen this year but there's also good
things I mean I think Edward Snowden is
a positive i think chelsea manning is a
positive thing that there's still this
mean those are true Americans as far as
i'm concerned and then the young turks
raised over four hundred thousand
dollars which cusco studs for the new
studio which just goes to show you that
there's people out there who care yeah
well we're going to get to the young
turks in a second but the bigger than
the young turks america america was a
good year value for america i think was
a bad year the reason why i think is a
bad year is that we are continuing on
the same path that we were on last year
and the year before and every year since
1980 basically which is that there is
greater and greater wealth inequality
the income gap is getting worse and
worse and the gap between those who have
everything and those who have so
precious few is just getting worse and
nothing has happened in 2013 in my mind
to derail that process in any way yeah i
mean this whole citizens united thing
has been juiced up you know more and
more and our supreme court seems just as
corporate i'm just as pro corporate as
any other part of our government now and
i think america is losing its way and
I've said this many times before like
America to me is more than just the
physical place is an idea it's an idea
that with equal opportunity we have
these certain inalienable rights and
those rights are disappearing I mean you
know the Fourth Amendment's pretty much
gone and utter it saddens me I wish we
could you know put on the brakes and
reverse our trajectory because i think
if we can
this path it's gonna be just worse yeah
well I think your particular getting on
about you know we were a nation of
immigrants and everyone wanted to come
here and I wonder if I if I was an
immigrant now an immigrant family from
anywhere from now on American out would
you feel that this is the place where
you can make it so they've already done
studies that's proven that the we now
have less economic mobility in the
United States than in other Western
democracies so it's going the eggs
exactly what Steve said it's going the
opposite way and why does income
inequality matter Jimmy because if
they've started also studied this and
they find out that the societies that
are the most and unequal inside their
societies suffer from the most societal
ills they suffer from more crime or uh
uh uh uh more oddity out of wedlock
birth every bad thing that comes with it
it's cut its it's not about the wealth
of the society but the inequality inside
of it and that goes the United States
and every other country too yeah so what
about for the world Goodyear bad yeah I
mean the main thing I guess is Syria has
been just locked in a civil war that
literally hundreds and out of the people
been killed we we didn't do anything and
it's and it's still going on uh and then
there's are now there's some their stuff
going down in Africa right now I mean
for the world did you did did the cause
of freedom and equality and all that
kind of stuff move in a good direction
overall you think Oh humanity I'm giving
you a break or entity uh I'm gonna give
you a bit kind of a kind of a cop-out
answer I suppose I think it's i'm going
to say good for the world in the sense
that i do believe that the arc of
history bends towards justice I think
Martin Luther King is correct if you
take any particular segment of it it may
be a bad bad period so 2013 alone is it
a good period or a bad period for the
world I don't know but I'm going to say
good just because I think things are
overall trending in the right direction
in terms of more equality and justice
for more people it's a generic answer I
think I'll be positive for you i
appreciate that what'd he get well
hopefully we've hit a tipping point you
know hopefully you know Occupy Wall
happen they crush them uh but there's
people now there's the Pope right and so
that's a big deal i think the Pope it I
can't believe that I'm really happy that
we have a pope right that's because I'm
so anti everything about the Pope but at
least he is he is hasn't of a message of
economic equality you know and that this
said that capitalism there that that
there's brutalities involved in a
capitalistic society that we need to
guard against that we're not doing
anymore and that in there so i think
that's a good thing for the world in
generating the Pope it of all the
leaders you know the Pope is gonna be
the guy who make up the biggest
difference going for in the next decade
I think in the world and now you know
the Pope starts talking about that stuff
next thing you know Brock Obama starts
talk about income inequality on Sundays
late yeah I all the Sun is talking about
it yeah you know I guess is right so I
think that's what has to happen you have
to chain we have to call out these phony
Christians right brush liebe UND
Catholic Catholic a Pope's not the heat
brush Limbaugh knows more about
Christianity than the Pope of preparing
Lee Corso yes we need to call out these
phony Christians who have turned Jesus
into a mascot of America who hates the
poor hates the gays and protects rich
people that's their Jesus and of course
the Pope is telling you that's not and
that's not the way we should go and
there are brutalities to capitalism that
we have to look at I think and we
haven't looked at them because the
theory behind capitalism that the right
proposes or the Iran people they say
well you have the opportunity we want
everyone to have the opportunity if I
was born poor I would work really hard
get an education and I would move upward
and if I didn't work hard I didn't
deserve to be well they don't ever look
at the facts though the what is the
outcome of your society well the fact
that most people don't reach the upper
levels but well that's their problem so
they so they don't care about really
what happens in practicality they only
carry about the only care about theories
which is what Iran people are all about
theories this purist idea of how the
world should be but it's not how it is
those books were so figure they know
they know what they're saying yeah
alright so away from the world for the
young turks good your bed year I mean
from where I'm sitting this was a pretty
great year you hit on it we raised a lot
of money that was crowd funded by the
people who watch what we do in care
what we do so I think this when you say
this was a changing year for the young
turks yet 2013 was a very very good year
for the young turks primarily the sense
that we we've kind of became a bigger
company in the sense that you know like
you guys are much more integral parts of
the young turks before 2013 Jimmy would
come on every now and then but but not
in a systematic way and we've kind of
gotten our independence from current TV
where we were very much wrapped up in in
in the TV show and there's a lot of
misconceptions out there you know Al
Gore never funded this company or had
any big role here Jen simply had a show
on Current TV right but that show took
up a lot of our time and our resources
we didn't get paid for Jack being on the
show gencon paid so that so getting that
off off our plate and being able to
focus on growing our company as an
independent enterprise you know bringing
out more talent creating more shows and
you know having a bigger following
having a louder voice has all been very
good but i will say that 2014 looks to
be a transformational year for the young
turks some really looking forward to
that well listen I've only been here for
it's been nine months it seems like I've
been here for a lot longer than that but
it's been pretty great and my final
question to you guys because people like
when you get personal for steve-o good
year bad year give me a highlight now
I'm putting you on the spot yeah 2013
was a great year for me look I I don't
believe in a God but I do thank my
blessings you know first of all I have a
great family I have amazing friends I
have a job that I love I get to work
with great people every single day I
still am healthy and can play sports not
quite at the level that would like to
play at close enough I'm happy with it
um and yet my kids are growing up and
there's been a lot of positive changes
in their lives and it's been a very very
good year but to be honest I think every
year has been a great year so well i'm
giving you two this is this is like when
the comedian kills and wow on right now
kidding and bring it bring it Jimmy
doing well I have to say my life has
been even better than Steve's I also
lived with his family and his kids
really admire me and we have a good time
together though I know I don't know if
this sounds sincere but it's true that i
would say 2013 probably my best year of
my life I just happier working with the
young turks has you know been a great
experience it's it's a it's really it
you know it's exciting it's interesting
it's fine I found something I like to do
as much as stand up which I never
thought I would and I love doing this
and i sold a book this year and so it
yet made a lot of great new friends I
feel like it's but I went off to
propecia that's been your big and I
gotta tell ya it is because you it kills
your libido right so when you when you
go on propecia kills you but when you go
off mine came back tenfold and I'm not I
tell people I'm back to [ __ ] my wife
I'm crazy about it I i buy i buy her
lingerie and stuff now and we look
forward to it and I'm just like this is
it's like we just started dating again
so good here for Jimmy Valmer Jimmy's
wife I would just like to say
specifically to Phil Robertson that I
asked a straight guy about his Goodyear
bad your he made it about his penis haha
the gay guy and finally I'll say this
was a great year I'm happy I'm healthy
I'm doing work that I love with people
that I love and I think we're doing
something good here and that's it we
will see you next year 2014 is going to
be a big one people stick with us we got
plenty more
you